la visita de la ministra del interior
suela brotherman se da 11 meses después
de que el gobierno británico y el de
Ruanda llegaron a un acuerdo de
inmigración para que los solicitantes de
asilo al Reino Unido fueran enviados a
ese país africano mientras se procesaba
su solicitud sin embargo hasta la fecha
ninguna persona ha sido enviada a Ruanda
porque la medida está estancada en los
tribunales británicos y se espera que en
el próximo mes de abril la corte falle
una apelación sobre si permitirá o no el
envío de estas personas a Ruanda en
junio de 2022 estaba programado el
primer envío de personas inmigrantes que
habían llegado a este país a través del
Canal de la Mancha u otras vías pero a
último minuto un fallo del tribunal
europeo de Derechos Humanos lo prohibió
Así que la ministra sola brotherman ya
está en Ruanda se reunirá con el
presidente de ese país con el ministro
de exteriores y con otros funcionarios
del Estado para según el gobierno
discutir planes para ser operativo el
acuerdo en breve y revisar los
alojamientos de miles de solicitantes de
asilo que se espera puedan ser enviados
a ese país Lo cierto es que esta medida
es altísimamente controversial por
inhumana y por cruel dado que Ruanda
tiene un bajísimo récord en protección
de Derechos Humanos pero lo cierto Es
que políticamente Richie sunak necesita
que el programa de Ruanda funcione para
poder cumplir una de sus promesas de
campaña de sus prioridades de detener la
llegada ilegal de barcos a través del
Canal de la Mancha que en el 2022 superó
las 45.000 personas